hello and welcome to the second part of
our tutorial on forecasting big time
series theory and practice where I
youngest house together with my
co-presenters Valentin to encourage
Timmy and assures kyun-jung Hwang we
will talk about some more modern
techniques for time series forecasting
in particular talking about deep
learning based approaches and some
applications and tooling that you can
use to apply those approaches to real
data so before we get into the meat of
how this all works I wanted to give a
brief overview of the timeline of how
neural networks have been used in the
forecasting domain and how this evolved
over time and this sort of mirrors a
little bit the development of how deep
learning as a field has developed so
forecasting was used to as an
application for deep learning based
techniques fairly early on starting in
69 where it was applied to or a variant
of very simple neural network techniques
were applied to weather forecasting and
then throughout the 80s and 90s there
was a lot of work on applying
multi-layer perceptrons what we nowadays
call feed-forward models - forecasting
individual time series and that's this
work culminated at the end of the 90s
there were a couple of influentials of
review articles reviewing all this large
body of work that was produced
throughout the 90s in the setting
so this forecasting with artificial
neural networks the state of the art an
empirical compressed comparison of
machine learning models for time series
forecasting and so on they came out of
all around 98 but they sort of gave a
message that okay well there was some
you know there's some good for applying
these techniques no they provide a great
deal of promise as one of the articles
put it there was also some uncertainty
around you know when do these techniques
actually
work when don't they work and what mics
makes them work so it was not a
unanimous success for these techniques
and forecasting and that sort of also
was shown in this m3 forecasting
competition which occurred in in 2000
where simpler techniques so exponential
smoothing and even simpler techniques
were overall outperforming neural
network based techniques and so in
together was sort of the general decline
of neural network techniques throughout
throughout the 2000s there was also less
work on your own network based
forecasting methods but this has since
you know since the deep learning
resurgence starting in 2012 with Alex
net winning the imagenet competition
this has been rekindled so there's now
of course also a rekindled interest in
applying all the techniques that have
led to great success and other domains
like an obedient computer vision also in
the forecasting setting and they have
also in the forecasting settings shown
to be very effective so in this last
sort of example of that is in 2018 there
was a the m4 competition which was a new
iteration of this M series of
competitions we're using a much larger
data set of time series a combination of
neural networks and classical techniques
was declared the winner so even even
though in the end in this m4 competition
the combination of techniques that
included a neural network approach an RN
approach in particular was declared the
winner there is there was stood up in
the still around that time this
consensus in quotes and the forecasting
community that neural network approaches
don't work and on the slide you have a
quote from Rob Heineman so one of the
prominent figures in this community
which reads as follows this supports the
general consensus and forecasting that
neural networks and other highly
nonlinear and nonparametric methods are
not well-suited to time series
forecasting
due to the relatively short nature of
most time series and so this is
basically a reflection of the way that
deep learning and neural network
techniques were used up to the time and
the community and that is basically that
they were applied to individual time
series so you given the time series up
to some time point and your task is to
forecast its future behavior now
nowadays in many practical applications
that is not really the task that you
really want to be solving in practice
you often have many more time series not
just one but you might have if you're
for example do forecasting in the retail
setting you might have time series that
record the sales of all the items that
you have in your store and you might not
don't have don't sell just one item like
you're selling hundreds or thousands or
even hundreds of thousands of items and
so you have a lot more data to work with
that you can leverage to create better
forecasts so our of you coming from from
this perspective is that neural networks
are actually great for learning complex
patterns from many time series when you
have what we call operational
forecasting problem so these are
forecasting problems where you have a
lot of time series you need to forecast
them with high frequency so for example
you want to not just make a forecast
once per month what you forecast them
every hour or every day and so and you
have many times seriously you have too
many time series to individually look at
each of them and sort of make an
individually adjust the model but you
need a model that can generate forecasts
for all these time series automatically
without manual intervention and in this
setting so this has been demonstrated
now and in several studies is that in
this setting your network techniques
work extremely well ok so this as I said
that m4 competition was which is I would
call the most influential of these
forecasting competitions was won by a
neural network based technique
and this competition contained in total
100,000 time series with different
frequency so the each frequency
contained a different number of series
not all of them contained particularly
large data sets but it was a mix of
different frequencies and in this
setting this hybrid approach using
basically an RNN combined with the form
exponential smoothing in the end produce
the best results this is a milestone in
demonstrating that this neural network
based techniques really work as in the
m3 competition the previous iteration of
this competition this was so the
opposite was shown that simpler
techniques if you look at multiple time
series and you averaged over all of them
simpler techniques perform on average
better than if you have something more
complex okay yeah so this was won by a
neural network the work done by a
Slovaks mill at uber so one question
that you might be having if you're
familiar with deep learning and you
might have used deep learning at a
different area like NLP or computer
vision right you might think ok deep
learning for forecasting this is the
time series right so why don't I just
use an RNN and be done with it right
shouldn't it just work basically is
there anything special about forecasting
that I need to take into account when
designing deep learning techniques or
models in the forecasting setting
setting right so why can I not just take
my model from NLP for example a language
model right and apply it in the
forecasting setting and get good results
and so the answer is well you actually
can more or less right you can take a
lot of these architectures and apply
them to the forecasting setting and
that's actually what a lot of the
literature nowadays is doing with great
success but you have to take some
peculiarities of the forecasting problem
into account and I will talk about a few
of those later but I'll mention them
here briefly so one of the challenges is
that is scaling so if you look at NLP
for example right you're and you do
language modeling for example your
inputs are words and
they're discrete units and you just
assign them some indices in your
vocabulary and you then and you predict
indices in your vocabulary so there's no
notion of scale and involved and the
same in computer vision but in
forecasting if you're forecasting across
multiple time series you might have the
problem that some of your time series
have a very different scale than others
right and you still want to learn
patterns for example seasonal behavior
across these time series ignoring the
scaling to some extent we are still
producing output that is scaled
appropriately and this is sort of a
challenge another challenge is that you
want in many cases you want probability
distributions as output so when you're
making a forecast you don't just want a
single number representing some notion
of the best forecast but you actually
want a probability distribution that
reflects your uncertainty about the
forecast that you're making because you
can then use this uncertainty
representation to make decisions so you
can use decision theory basically
computing the expected value under this
probability distribution of your of
whatever loss you're trying to optimize
and can use that to make this optimal
decisions
another challenge might be sample
efficiencies so in many cases you might
for each individual time series you
might not have that much data so for
example if you take the hourly data
sorry if you take a yearly data right
then for any for most of the problems
that of practical importance you will
not have more than let's say 10 or 20
years of data all right so your your
model has to be able to learn from 10 or
20 observations for time series trying
to take into account learning well
basically by learning from multiple time
series simultaneously but for each
individual time series you might have
only a small number of examples and
finally there might be a challenge that
you want to might want to incorporate
prior knowledge about what you think how
these time series behave right so one so
prominent example is that if I have a
retailer forecasting problem where
trying to predict the demand for certain
products then one thing I might want to
take into account is the price of them
asking for these products right and as I
increase the price you might want to
have your model react in the way that
the demand drops right things get more
expensive demand drops and you might
want to incorporate this as prior
knowledge into your model rather than
trying to learn this from the data okay
so this is the the outline of this part
of the tutorial first we'll talk about a
little bit going from regression to
feed-forward models so this is of the
basic model category that a lot of the
work and the 90s was based on we talked
about that and then we'll talk a little
bit of different kinds of basic model
architectures and model structures I
will briefly talk about training neural
network models though there's really
nothing special about how you train
these models in the forecasting setting
versus how you train them in NLP of
computer vision settings so any thing
you know is directly applicable to that
as well and then my colleagues will talk
about different architectures in
particular convolutional neural networks
I would like to talk about your neural
networks we'll talk a little bit about
more techniques how you can produce
probabilistic forecasts how you output
from your forecasting systems can be
probabilistic with neural networks and
then and finally we'll talk about what
we call deep probabilistic models which
is basically combinations of latent
variable models that were classically
used in the forecasting setting with
sort of modern deep learning techniques
okay so let's get started so we talked a
little bit in the first half of the
tutorial about so one of the simplest
techniques that you could use to
forecast given an output values at T at
some time point t one of the simplest
ways you could do that is to take some
inputs at time T so XT would
could be your future value see they
could be so for example that the price
that I mentioned previously but there
could also be lacked values of the time
series itself so XT could be for
examples at t minus 1 right so the
previous value of the time series and I
could take all those inputs XT and a
computer weighted sum of these inputs
and say ok my weight at some of these
inputs is my output at time T so that T
equals to this inner product of W
transpose X T and I do that for every
time step right so for every time step
now I have a different feature vector X
T I use the same weight vector W and I
produce the output set T and this is
sort of the basically one of the
simplest models you could imagine for
doing forecasting there's the linear
regression from XT to ZT and now what a
feed-forward model does basically is
just saying ok let's take that linear
function W transpose X T and let's make
it non linear right and the way we make
it nonlinear it basically is by saying
ok let's apply a linear transformation
to my XT right and then let's apply a
nonlinear transformation on top of this
linearly transformed output and then
let's repeat this process right so we
always have a linear transformation or
an affiant transformation in general
followed by some non-linearity Sigma
which then gets reused as the input to
the next layer but this does the
structure of the model in this case they
stayed the same so you're given some XT
which are the feature is a time point t
and you're trying to predict the values
at T which is the desired output value
at time T ok so if you're you know a
graphical representation you end up with
something that looks like this right you
might all have seen these sort of
standards neural network diagrams of
feed-forward neural network so I well
you have the inputs at the bottom here
you pass through several so-called
hidden layers right which apply these
affine function followed by the
nonlinear activation and then at the top
you have the output values at T
and you do this for every time point
with that features at timepoint
xt plus1 here for example producing the
outputs at that at time t plus 1 right
so every hidden layer as I said computes
this affine function of the output from
the previous hidden layer so a weighted
sum of the previous hidden layer plus
some offset passed through my linearity
and it turns out that this sort of
architecture is very very flexible
general function estimate estimation
procedure in particular as you make
these layers wider and wider
you can basically approximate any
arbitrary function as closely as you
want and so in in general then the wider
your hidden layers are and the more of
them you have with the more complex the
function that you're approximating can
be okay well so now we have this generic
to the function approximation technique
that's great so then the main advantage
over just using a linear model is that
we can learn complex input-output
relationships right which means that we
have to do less manual work so
previously if you wanted to have a
certain nonlinear behavior of ZT modeled
as dependent on your inputs XT the only
way you could do that since you were
using a linear function would be to
manually engineer some features XT that
would produce the desired behavior now
if you have a knock you can learn
nonlinear function mapping from X to Z
you can try to learn that transformation
directly without doing manual feature
engineering so that's one of the main
advantages of going from the linear
model to a nonlinear model the main
disadvantage of course is that in order
to estimate this function from data you
need more data that you basically need
more training data because there are
just more parameters to learn and the
second sort of disadvantage might be
that you need to be a bit more careful
in how you learn and and tune your model
in order to get good results
and since these models tend to be a bit
more sensitive to particular
parameterizations sensitive to the
scaling of the inputs they might be
sensitive to things like the learning
rate since now you're solving a non
convex optimization problem and so all
of these might be they might need to be
tuned in order to achieve good results
okay so this was sort of the general
introduction for how you get from a
linear model to a nonlinear multi-layer
perceptron or feed-forward model and now
I wanted to talk about a little bit
about two different octogenarian
architectures that people use to apply
deep learning to the forecasting setting
the one is shown on the left here is
basically what I showed you before we
basically call it the one-to-one
architecture which is where you're at
time point t you get some features XT as
input and you produce a single output ZT
as basically your your forecast for that
particular time point all right and you
do that for every time point that you
want to forecast for and the way you
train these models is basically given
pairs of xt & ZT right and you make a
prediction for ZT given your xt s and
you try to minimize the error that
you're getting another sort of basic
model structure is the so called
sequence to sequence or many to many
models which are shown on the right here
which looks slightly differently and
here so the setup is that there is some
fixed forecast forecast time here which
I'm showing in this dashed line and what
the model gets to do it gets to look at
everything that happened before this
dashed line so all these values that
appeared here and then it tries to
predict the entire sequence of
observations following that particular
time point all right so the model gets
to input or gets as input these
different time points the values the
feature values for these time points
before the dashed line computes some
sort of representation
from that and then use a set
representation to predict the future
okay and sort of every many of the the
models or the generic forecasting a
generic deep learning architectures I
should say that you can can use so RN n
CN NS transformers and so on can always
be used in either that's sort of one to
one basic model structure or in the
sequence the sequence setting and we
will see examples for both of these as
we go along okay so let me talk a bit
more about this sort of one-to-one
structure also sometimes called the
generative model because you're
generating the outputs that T given some
inputs at time X T so basically what
you're trying to do is that every time
point right you make some prediction so
you make a prediction set T and you want
to see okay how well that's my
prediction reconstruct the original time
series XT right that especially how I
train this model and in comparison
alright you're looking at if you look at
the sequence the sequence architecture
here now you have a function that gets
us input multiple time points right and
also produces multiple time points as an
output so the goal here is that not to
look at every time point how well does
my my model predict each time point but
the the goal is to reconstruct the
what's called the decoding sequence so
everything to the right of this bar here
conditioned on everything that happens
to the left of the law okay so this is
conceptually as a form of multivariate
regression one can think of this okay so
this has of two generic model
architectures and we'll come back to how
they get applied and and combined with
different kinds of deep learning
specific deep learning models but before
we go there I wanted to briefly talk
about how do you train these models and
as I said this is not nothing specific
to the forecasting setting anything you
know about how to train your networks
that you have learned and other domains
and NLP
good a vision for example are directly
transferable right and so the the
general recipe to train any of these
models in any domain really is to first
pick a class of functions right some
neural network architecture in our case
that is takes its input some features X
and has some parameters theta and then
learn the parameters theta by maximizing
some notion or
well I should say minimizing some notion
of error right on maximizing some notion
of utility on a training set so you have
examples of inputs and outputs you have
some notion of measuring error which I
call L here so some loss function and
you compare what your model predicts to
what the true value was using this loss
function you send that up over all your
training examples and you try to
minimize this overall cost with respect
to the parameters of your model
very generic overall recipe and the
optimization algorithm of choice for for
doing that for neural network so for a
neural network function class is
nowadays stochastic gradient descent or
variance there off and this works as
shown here so basically what you do at
each iteration so this is a iterative
algorithm that you run until convergence
is at each iteration you pick a randomly
mini batch of examples or some fixed
number of examples from your training
set based on these examples you compute
your loss function so the sum over all
these examples of this individual losses
and you compute its gradient and then
based on the gradient you take you do an
update to your parameters at that
iteration so you initialize your
parameter somehow randomly and then at
every iteration you compute the gradient
and you take a step in the negative
gradient direction weighted by some
learning rate and then as a final step
you adjust learning rate a little bit
and depending on which optimization
specific variant of SGD you're using
this will either be done automatic
or you will have some manual scheduler
for adjusting the learning rate okay so
this is of the very basic rest recipe of
SGD that we'll also use to train any of
these architectures that we will talk
about okay so one key ingredient here is
of course the loss function right and in
the forecasting setting you can imagine
the loss function that we're using might
be a bit different from the loss
functions that you're using in other
settings and in particular the loss
function that you are going to use
depends on whether you're interested in
just making a point forecast so
producing a single best estimate of what
we think the value at time T should be
so that D hat here or whether we're
producing a probabilistic forecast which
means we're producing a probability
distribution over the possible values at
time T which also encodes our
uncertainty so in the simplest setting
and the point forecasting setting we can
basically use any loss function that
people also use understand the
progression setting so that the most
prominent example would be squared loss
so where basically you take your true
values that T you subtracted from your
estimated value that you had and you
square it that gives you some error at
time T and if I minimize this right then
I will in the end hopefully get close to
my true value set T so this is one
example squared error also commonly used
are things like absolute error or
asymmetric versions of absolute error so
any error of function for comparing two
real numbers you can also use in the
forecasting setting for the distribution
forecast setup is a bit more complicated
because now you basically have to
compare probability distribution F T to
a single value that you have observed to
Z T right so now you're not comparing
two objects of the same type but you're
comparing a probability distribution to
a single number and the way you do that
is by using a so-called scoring rule
which is basically doing exactly that
so it's a loss function that compares a
probability distribution to a single
number and one sort of prominent example
of such a loss function is negative log
likelihood so you take your density
corresponding to your distribution the
forecast distribution you take the
negative logarithm of that and apply it
evaluate it at your observed points at T
and that gives you a scoring rule that
you can use to to evaluate how well your
forecasted distribution matches the data
or that you've observed another
alternative scoring rule is the CRPS and
we'll come back to that when we talk
about different ways of representing
these probability distributions ft later
in the tutorial okay so as the first
class of more advanced deep learning
based forecasting models I want to talk
about recurrent neural networks and so
for for recap so the MLP you saw them at
the the simple feed-forward model had
looked something like this right you're
given inputs at time T and you're trying
to produce an output at time T and you
do this for every time step T so
independently and you're using the same
models but there is no connection
between these individual passes through
the network at each time step right so
basically what you're doing is you're
losing you're throwing away the
information that there is actual
actually a sequential relationship
between Z T and Z T plus 1 and you
basically pretending that that doesn't
exist and yet you can independently
predict set T from the inputs X T now if
you remember what we've talked about in
the first part of the tutorial
the subspace state space model formalism
for for forecasting under which of
exponential smoothing and ARIMA models
fall then the basic approach there was
basically that you had a an underlying
unobserved latent state which I call L T
here and this latent states have evolved
over
and carried information forward over
time and then what you observed at time
T is the output that he was a function
of this latent state I didn't remind
exponential smoothing cases as to linear
function of this latent state and then
there was also some additional input
coming from the observations that you
had at at time T so from the additional
features from xt and so the final output
was some combination of what was
represented in your latent hidden state
and what you observed in terms of
features at time point t but there was
this connection between the different
latent states which carried information
forward through time now the basically
the so if we look at this right so that
this is basically if we ignore the
latent state here for ZT this is just a
linear regression model right set T
equal to W transpose X T now we have
this this latent stage which we let in
state which we add linearly now in the
neural network setting we can similarly
go from our feed-forward model right
where we have this individual node is
now a more complex nonlinear function
two recurrent or time evolving version
of this model right and so the way we do
that is by an additional two the inputs
at time T which we use to predict the
output set T at that time point the
model also gets to see the output of the
previous at the previous time step so
there especially a hidden state that
does steal the output of what this this
neuron here produces or this this MLP
produces at some time point and that
gets passed forward to the next state as
an additional input okay so this this
slide makes it a bit more precise so the
if you look at the the figure on the
right here so the simplest recurrent
neural network you could imagine right
takes as input a time point XT some
feature vector X T that goes into some
function that computes HT
down here but in addition to XD h t- one
is also fed in as an additional input so
in order to compute HD you get the model
gets to look at HT minus one and the
feature is XT and then it applies
whatever function is used to
parameterize this RNN model I guess on
the simplest case it could just be that
there's a linear function acting on HT
minus 1 and the denia function acting on
X T which then together it gets passed
through some non-linearity okay and then
ZT is again just a nonlinear function
applied to some denia mapping on this HD
so this is this output relationship
right so there's now instead of just one
function that maps from XD to ZT we
actually have two functions one that
maps from the previous hidden state HT
minus 1 and the current inputs XT to the
new hidden state HT so this is this
first function here and then there is a
second function and what gets us gets us
from the hidden state to the observation
ok so now we have basically for any such
are an and model what we have to specify
are these of the the dynamics of the
hidden state so how do we get from HT
minus 1 to HD and then this readout
mechanism how do we get from HT to the
output ZT that we want to predict and so
the the central idea right is the same
as in the states there is modeling
approach that you have some interesting
information that you've extracted from
the data up to time point t so this of
yesterday's information right and then
at time point t you see additional
features which gives you new knowledge
which on the one hand you want to
incorporate into your of representation
of all the information that you've seen
so far so that's your hidden state and
you also want to use it to make
predictions for the forecast for the
current state and that's the output ZT
and that's the same as in the state
space model
right so the most I guess prominent
obvious of RNN architecture is this
so-called long short term memory or lsdm
architecture and what this specifies is
basically a way of specifying the
dynamic under which your hidden state
evolves that is slightly more complex
and what I've shown on the previous
slide and that the reason why this is
needs to be more complex is basically
that it gets around some of the issues
that you have with training is of more
simple RNN models in particular around
what's called the vanishing gradient
problem so basically where as you try to
back propagate your errors from some
time point in the future to some earlier
time point the the gradients become
smaller and smaller and the way these
gradients decrease in the substandard
Elmen RNN model is they basically decay
very quickly and this lsdm model in
using a some more complicated update
mechanism for the state gets around that
but so I didn't want to get into too
much detail about how this works as a
great blog post that I recommend you
look into if you want to know how this
works in detail what I wanted to point
out is that the the mechanism by which
this the sea state here so LS diems now
I actually have a two component hidden
state that evolves over time and one
part of that is called C the other one
is called H the sea state actually
evolves according to something that is
looks very much like the exponential
smoothing idea that we've seen in the
first part where you take your old a ct-
one and you multiply it by some factor
which is called the forget gate and
actually that decreases that failure
this lead in quotes forgets part of that
information that is stored in there and
then you add to it some new stuff so
some basically something that gets
computed from the input XT and your
previous HT
and you scale that by a factor as called
the input gate so that basically says
okay how much of this new information
that I'm seeing at time point t do I
want to include in my memory okay so in
this equation looks very similar to two
exponential smoothing right so if you
look at the general model structures
again and consider okay how can this be
applied and by using RN ends to model
these individual cells there has been
work on both sides of these model
structures so there has been a lot of
work on using the canonical one-to-one
models in the context of RN ends in
particular the D PI R model which I'll
talk about a bit more in detail about a
RM BN d p-- l STM's and there is a few
more which will have in the references
and then there is also in the sequence
the sequence setting with RN ends have
been applied successfully in particular
the this m q RN n model was applied and
the retailer forecasting setting and
diffusion convolutional are ends and
also many others so both of these model
structures have been combined with our
names and they both work well in
practice okay so that's I guess one
thing I I will also get back to later is
that there's I'm showing you both of
these and there is currently no good
guidance in to when you should use one
over the other I'll talk a little bit
about advantages of each of these
approaches but just note that both of
these have general basic model
structures have been combined with our
names and both successfully okay so one
thing one of the models in particular I
wanted to talk about is this deep our
deep ir model which uses this canonical
RNN structure so basic exactly what i
would have showed you before at time
point t you get as inputs on xt you
produce
output ZT and you also have some hidden
side htu it then gets passed to the next
time step in addition with the new
features that arrives there so one
addition that these deep deeper our
model made is that in addition to the
the hidden state gets gets fed forward
from one time step to the next the model
also actually gets the previous output
value as an input at the next time step
or in general it actually gets multiple
of these previous output values at
various lags in the past as input and
this basically now instead of sort of
directly of having to remember all the
information and the state right the
model can now at every time points of
directly refer back at what were the the
previous output values at previous time
steps and use that to compute the output
value and the hidden state at the
current time point okay so this is of
another way of putting that the current
current features get fed into the hidden
state at time T as well as the hidden
state from the previous time step as
well as the observation from the
previous time step and that all gets
used to compute a probability
distribution over the output ZT as
what's called autoregressive input and
this actually helps in many settings if
you choose the the lagged values at
which which time points you include into
this into this hidden state at time
point t this gives you a way to combine
what you would do with a feed-forward
model based on lags with an RNN model
and episode both components can model
various aspects of the temporal
evolution okay so another thing that
this d by our model did in addition to
incorporating this autoregressive input
is that it actually supports
probabilistic forecasting in the sense
that it doesn't just produce the best
estimate for the predictions at t but it
actually produces a probability
distribution over the T at every time
point and this probability distributions
at T is parametrized by the output of
the neural network at that time which we
call YT here so the network outputs YT
and then this YT is gets converted into
parameters of a probability distribution
which are then used to score the actual
observations at T so as an example here
we have for example you could could
assume that your outputs at T follows a
normal distribution which is
parameterised by its mean so mu T as
well as at standard deviation Sigma T so
YT would be a two dimensional vector
containing mu T and Sigma T and based on
that would give you a distribution over
the possible values that you would
expect to see at time point t and then
for any given that T we could compute
the scoring rule that I was talking
about before so now we have a
probability distribution that we want to
compare to a single value and one way to
do that would be to look at the negative
log likelihood so we could evaluate the
probability of probability density of a
particular point that we observed that t
given the parameters that were outputted
by our network and we could use that as
the loss function for training our
network and this is exactly what this D
by our have proposed cheaper a model did
and in addition to doing this just with
Gaussian distributions you can of course
do it with any parametric distribution
that you might think is applicable to a
data in particular in the DPR paper they
used negative binomial distributions for
count data which turned out to be quite
effective so one thing you might be me
wondering is that I've talked about no
how are you during training basically
I've given the feature is how you
compute the the output from the model
and how do you compute the error based
on that but how do you actually compute
the forecast right so for a single for
the next
timepoint right if my goal was to just
predict the next time point so I get
observations up to some time point t and
I want to predict the output at time T
plus one so that that's easy right so
then I'm given basically the inputs at
time point t plus one and I just predict
with the previously given output which
is my true observation I include that
and I make a forecast but how do I
actually do that if I want to predict
multiple time steps I had well the the
trigger since we have a generative model
which at every time point allows us to
predict the probability distribution
over the next time step we can actually
draw samples from that distribution
right so we can take we can at time
point the last time point that we
actually observed right we can compute
the probability distribution over the
next time point and we can draw a sample
from that distribution and use the
sample value as the input for the next
time step and so on right and we can do
that this drawing sample is not just one
so we can do it many times giving us a
representation of the entire probability
distribution over all future time steps
in the form of so-called sample paths so
we have a c1 sample that gets propagated
forward in time and we do as multiple
times that gives us multiple paths of
possible futures that represent our
uncertainty over the behavior of the
system in the future okay so this was
sort of in the 1 to 1 generative model
setting now I want to briefly talk about
the sequence to sequence structure where
we have the many-to-many setting so we
have in two parts to such a model
typically one is called the encoder
which basically takes observations up to
this black line and produces some
representation HT and then we have a
so-called decoder which takes this
representation HT and produces a
forecast for the entire decoding
sequence in the future and in this
this forecast here doesn't have to be an
individual value for each time point but
it could also be a probabilistic
forecast so we could have a full joint
probability distribution parameterised
for all time steps after the black line
so one such model was the RNN MLP model
proposed by when at all which basically
combines an iron and encoder so during
them so on the left of this bar now you
have iron and running from time step to
time step like we had previously in the
generative model but then so that at the
last time step produces some final
hidden state ATT and then we can use
this HT as an input to a simple
feed-forward MLP model in addition with
possibly some additional feature as you
to produce our output and this is
basically what they proposed an RNN MLP
model as one possible sequence the
sequence architecture but of course it's
not the only option right you could also
have an an RNN as an encoder and an RN
as a decoder we're now basically the
hidden state at time T of the encoder
becomes the first hidden state of the
decoder and then you might have
additional inputs in this decoding
sequence that you can use to as inputs
to the decoder and the difference
between sort of the canonical
architecture versus the sequence the
sequence architecture is that I mean if
you look at this picture you might think
okay this looks now looks basically the
same as it did before the main
difference is that the models this
encoder model and the decoder model here
can actually be completely different
right there's no requirement that the
model that you use during during this
encoding part of the sequence is the
same as the one that you use during the
decoding part
okay another example that we'll talk a
little bit more about when we talk about
the cnn's in the second part of the
tutorial is that you could have for
example a CNN encoder and then use what
the out the final output from the CNN as
an input to your RN decoder right then
you have a CNN RN and model you can of
course flip this around and have an iron
and CNN or in CNN CNN know any of these
combinations are of course possible this
is a fairly flexible generic framework
and all of these these combinations that
I just mentioned actually have been
tried out in the literature and you'll
find a paper about any of them as no as
I said before there's no clear winner
about which one of those will actually
work better than another one in a given
setting right I mean if you read the
literature of course whatever you're
reading about right now is the one that
will work better but in general so that
if you look at some of this comparative
studies there hasn't been so the clear
will never been declared that works
better in all settings okay so in the in
the sequence the sequence setting how
does this the training work and one way
that that so now be you have these these
two time windows when you have your
encoding sequence and your decoding
sequence and you need to somehow choose
them relative to what you've actually
observed in the data right so in this
example here I have let's say I have
observed three time series right and I
have observed them up to this green line
so let's say Green Line is today right
and my goal is to make a forecast for
these time windows that follow the green
line so I haven't actually observed this
part yet so I don't know that then what
is typically done is that you take some
some windows in your of some fixed
length that you look at you somehow put
in your you place them in the past of
your time series and these windows have
two parts again right they have this
encoding portion and then they have this
decoding portion well this decoding
portion is exactly as long as you want
your forecasts to be
all right so if you want for example to
have you have an hourly data set and you
want to make forecasts for one day ahead
then this decoding portion of your data
set would be 24 time steps long right
and the encoding portion can be as long
as you want it to be but of course it
should include as enough data to capture
any of the the temporal dependencies
that you want to learn right so
obviously you do your training by this
sort of window slicing approach so you
take these windows and you place them in
your in your training time series and
you shift them around so you can
basically take multiple of these windows
at different locations thereby
generating multiple training examples
from each time series that you're trying
to train the other model law and then
again your your loss function that you
use right now the loss is basically your
only computed on this the right part of
this window right the left part is only
computed used to compute the hidden
representation that you use for making
the forecast but the right part is where
the loss gets evaluated and any of the
losses that I talked about before so
negative like likelihood in the
distribution forecasting setting or l1
l2 loss quantile losses so asymmetric l1
losses any of those could be used as a
loss function to compute the error that
your model is making in this decoding
sequence portion right and so in the
prediction setting now of course if you
actually it's listed during training
what I just said right and during
prediction now if I'm at the Green Line
what I will do is I will place my these
red windows such that my current time
aligns with this the black line that I
was showing before so exactly between
the encoding sequence and the decoding
sequence and I just compute the decoding
sequence from my model
so I wanted to just give one reference
of a very successful model that that
applied this techniques so cargo ran ran
a forecasting competition using
Wikipedia web traffic data so the goal
was to predict how many people would be
visiting a particular Wikipedia page and
the winning model actually used such a
sequence the sequence architecture with
the GI you based Ireland Model S of both
the encoder and the decoder so in the
encoder you would get to see
observations up to some time point the
giu model would ingest those
observations and compute some output
encoder state and that encoder state
would then get passed to the decoder giu
which would compute in an auto
regressive way the predictions and so
exactly using this architecture and
shown to be very effective in this web
traffic forecasting competition so as I
said both of these approaches have
strengths and weaknesses so in
particular the domain weakness or one of
the disadvantages of this of one-to-one
approach the canonical approach is that
the same the model as I said stays the
same between the the input sequence so
that the encoder sequence and the
decoder sequence when there's really not
this notion of encoder and decoder
that's just one model that you use
during training and prediction and that
means that the input features that
you're feeding into the model and during
prediction need to be the same as the
ones that you have during training and
this actually is sometimes not very well
aligned with what you have in practice
so for example if you go back to this
example that I mentioned earlier where I
want to do demand forecasting and I want
to use price as one of the inputs I'm
for every of the items that I have sold
in the past and I know what the price
was when I sold them but I might not
actually know what the price will be in
the
future all right so one way to get
around that would be of course to say I
take my prices in the past and I build a
separate model to predict the prices and
then I used to predict the prices as
inputs to my model but it would be nicer
if I could somehow train a model that
implicitly directly would predict the
prices for me so I wouldn't give it the
prices as inputs in the decoding
sequence but the model would someone
implicitly learn how the similar prices
have evolved and into the future in
another previously basically so the the
sequence the sequence setup allows me to
do that as I can have the input features
that I feed in here during the encoding
features encoding sequence can be
completely disjoint from what I feed in
here doing decoding right and since I
trained the model also in exactly this
way during training the models of learns
to deal with the fact that some of the
inputs might not be available for making
the forecasts so for example in this
sequence a sequence setting it's very
easy to deal with this missing price
information one downside of the sequence
the sequence setup is said depending on
what I use as a decoder
I may have to retrain this model if I
want to change my prediction lengths
right so the thus canonical model is
trained to only predict the next time
step so if I want to predict for ten ten
steps I can just unroll it and sample
for ten times steps forward as I don't
need to fix the forecast horizon ahead
of time but in the sequence the sequence
setting I basically train the model to
predict exactly some number of steps and
I might need to retrain my model if I
want to now suddenly produce a different
length forecast so as some of the
differences between the models at all so
of course there might be differences in
in training so for example it might be
easier to train these one-to-one models
especially if you don't have so much
training data
available depending on how long these
sequences are here in the sequence the
sequence models this might become more
challenging to learn because basically
all the information first needs to get
compressed into this one hidden state
here which then gets decoded so it's a
more complex learning problem okay so
that was sort of a bit of a discussion
around our end models and different
architectures about how you can can
combine them and now I wanted to talk
about a little bit more about this
problem of getting probabilistic
forecasts out from your networks and if
you look at so for example if you look
at a lot of blog posts that you might
have seen on the web that explain how
you would do forecasting with no
networks they almost exclusively talk
about predicting point forecasts so
making individual best value predictions
for a given sequence and this is I guess
fairly natural right because this is
fairly there's a similar to what you do
in the regression setting and it's an
easier it's a fairly intuitive thing to
understand how that works but in
practice this probabilistic forecast
which gives you give you a notion of
uncertainty actually much more valuable
so I will spend a bit more time
explaining how how you could go about
getting these probabilistic forecasts
right so the goal now is that I have
some observed time series I only observe
individual values for the time series so
I never get to observe the uncertainty
that I had around any individual points
right I just have a single sequence of
of individual values that I observe but
I want to make a probabilistic forecast
which it either at each time point gives
me a probability distribution of what
the values at that time point or even
better gives me a joint probability
distribution over some time range into
the future which I could represent
either in some parametric way or using
the sample path representation that I
mentioned before
so how do i how could I go about getting
these probabilistic forecasts well the
simplest one is to say okay let me first
generate a point forecast and then
somehow look at the arrows that I'm
getting from my point forecasting model
when running it on some real data and
use those residuals from the model to
estimate a distribution so this is a
very standard approach for getting
confidence intervals or probabilistic
forecasts for any sort of point
prediction technique and it's very
simple to implement but it might be more
complex to maintain as use of evolving
your predictive model and the reason for
that is that it might be no because you
know basically learning two models on
top of each other the second model might
somehow correct for the mistakes that
your first model is making in some way
that you're not there are not quite as
apparent as if you had a single model
that basically went directly from input
to distribution output a segments of
downside of this approach is that the
distribution of the values was the error
distribution is not directly taken into
account and estimating the model right
and there might be some mismatch so for
example if I trained the model using
squared error that would sort of
implicitly making the assumption that my
data is normally distributed but
afterwards I might actually estimate the
distribution that is very non normal and
so this might be some mismatch between
what I what I use as of an assumption
when I estimate my point forecasting
model versus what the what I use
afterwards to estimate my errors
so the second thing I could do and which
is basically what I was describing
earlier I said I could use some
parametric output distribution so for
example I could assume that my output
follows a Gaussian distribution and
instead of outputting a single value at
each time step I trained my model to
output the parameters of this
distribution so if I assume a gaussian I
would train the model to output a mean
and a variance and then use one of these
scoring rules like the log likelihood to
evaluate how well does my distribution
fit the data that I've observed
so one downside of this approach is that
it makes studies you have to make fairly
strong assumptions about the data right
you have to assume it follows some
parametric distribution like a Gaussian
or negative binomial and it cannot
directly capture complex distributions
by I mean if you take some of these
simple distributions right if you assume
it's Gaussian and only thing the model
will ever be able to capture is Gaussian
outputs right it cannot go beyond what
you've specified but of course you can
make the this output parametric output
distributions more complex right for so
for example one thing you could do is
instead of assuming the output follows a
single Gaussian distribution you could
assume it follows the mixture of
Gaussian distributions and that gives
you already as you increase of the
mixture component and your mixture this
already gives you a lot of flexibility
and so you can make these parametric
outputs also as flexible as you want but
you have to specify now exactly how
flexible do you want it to be ahead of
time so one positive aspect of this way
of modeling the output is said if you
assume for example your data is Gaussian
well then you only have two parameters
to learn at each time step right this is
fairly manageable versus some of these
other techniques or the nonparametric or
semi-parametric techniques might have a
much larger number of parameters but on
the upside they might make less strong
assumptions about the data so they might
for example learn the empirical
distribution function of the data
directly in a non parametric way and so
my basically become more complex as you
see more data and therefore can capture
also more complex distributions but on
the downside they might become a larger
number of parameters which may or may
not be a problem since we will be using
the deep learning model to parameterize
these distributions which just can
output a larger number of parameters for
us so that we don't have to tune them by
hand or something okay so one of the
challenges of using zuv neural network
techniques for forecasting that I
mentioned the initial
that time series might have very
different magnitudes right so if I have
a data set of multiple time series some
of my time series might be on completely
different scales than others so for
example if I'm in the retail setting I
might have some items that sell many
hundred units per day but I might have
some other items that only sell once per
year once the month and so if I want to
learn across across learn patterns
across all of these time series and I
might have to do something about
normalizing the magnitude of the
different time series and so one fairly
generic way of doing that is to if I
have a time series for some and I
observe it for some number of time
points here then I can look at what is
the the marginal distribution of that
time series obviously I pretend that all
these values here were independent and
look at what is the distribution now if
I computed those marginal and I can take
this this marginal distribution and try
to transform it in some way by basically
applying a transformation on my time
series data and this is a very old
approach championed by box-cox in the
60s initially and what their approach
visually was that at the time most of
the techniques could only deal with
normally distributed data so what they
try to do is basically to take their
time series data and apply a
transformation that would make their
data more normal so basically if I had a
distribution that looked more like this
what is shown on the left here so
somehow some some skewed distribution
that doesn't look quite normal then if I
could apply some transformation to each
of the observations that would make it
look more like a normal distribution as
shown on the right here and that would
sort of allow me to apply a simpler time
series model that only can deal with
normally distributed data to my
transformed data and and then afterwards
that I want to make a forecast I can
transform this the forecast back into
the original domain
alright so in general the idea is that
you take your original input you apply
some transformations that in some way
makes it easier for your model to learn
from this transformed data and then you
apply the inverse transformation
afterwards to get back to your forecasts
so in this the the box-cox transform is
one of the simplest such transformations
it's basically just a power transform so
X here is my input value that I observe
at any of the time points and what I do
is basically I just take X to some power
lambda which is the free parameter here
subtract 1 and divide by lambda and that
gives you my out my output Y my
transformed output and I can invert this
and get back to X given some transform
value Y and now basically I would
typically try to choose Y such that the
data that I get out after transformation
looks as Gaussian as it can and you can
do that basically by maximizing the
probability of the transformed data
under a Gaussian this what box uncocks
did in the 60s so a slightly more
generic approach what sort of in the
same spirit is that instead of applying
a fixed parametric transform like the
power transform I could take my input
data and I could estimate its empirical
distribution function so the empirical
CDF what I showed on the in the middle
here actually what I plotted here is
that the quantile functions of the
universe of the CDF but if I took the
CDF if I took my data and mapped it
through the CDF then if I have perfectly
estimated the CDF that Denner generated
my data I would get out something that
would be uniformly distributed between 0
and 1 and this is known as the
probability integral transform so if you
transform any random variable through
its cumulative distribution function you
get out something that is a uniformly
distributed random variable and I can
use this trick basically now to convert
any
data was some any arbitrary marginal
distribution into data that is
marginally uniformly distributed right
so in practice what I could do is I
could set aside some portion of my
training data for each time series
compute the empirical CDF on that
portion transform the rest of my time
series through the CDF and now I have
marginally uniformly distributed random
variables and then try to output a
probability distribution on the unit
interval to make predictions so the
fairly generic technique works very well
in practice a very similar technique
that's has been fairly popular in the
past and now it's of coming back a
little bit in the forecasting setting is
what's known as binning and here the
idea basically has said instead of
treating your observed time series as a
sum real valued quantity over which you
have to estimate a probability
distribution you break your input domain
into different bins so different sub
intervals into which part of your data
Falls and then instead of predicting the
exact real value you would you're
predicting basically which bin or a
probability distribution over the
different bins that your data can fall
into so this this pinning approach gets
directly gets around the problem of
scaling right because there's now
there's no scale involved you're just
not predicting discrete outputs like you
would do in an NLP for example so any of
the techniques you would use they're
directly apply here now after you've
performed that binning but of course now
you have the problem of how do you
choose these bins right how do you pick
these dashed lines and they're multiple
possible strategies so you could pick
them for example for each time series
individually by for example estimating
the range of the time series and then
either doing equally spaced bins or
what's called quantile bins which are
basically bins which have
an equal number of points in each of the
bins or you could try to do some part of
global binning where you try to first
scale your time series in some way and
then apply at the same binning to all of
them and both of these I mean all of
these combinations work in some cases
some depending on your application some
might work better than others and you'll
probably have to experiment which one
works well in your application but this
is a fairly powerful generic data
transformation technique that allows you
to transform your data to get around
some of the issues that you would have
in the forecasting setting compared to
other settings where you have discrete
inputs initially okay a final thing that
I wanted to talk about is different
representations for probability
distributions as outputs from your
neural network model so previously what
I talked about basically is predicted if
you wanted to predict the probabilistic
output then I said okay either you could
use a parametric form for your density
or you could use some transformation and
then use a parametric form but in all
those cases I was basically talking
about parameterizing the density
function somehow right but the density
function is only one of several possible
representations of a distribution in
particular the more common ones are the
cumulative distribution function which
is the integral of the density basically
and the quantile function which is the
inverse of the CDF and so instead of
modeling the density function somehow
with some parametric form I can equally
model the CDF with some parametric form
or I can model the quantile function
with the parametric form and so
depending on your setting some might be
easier to model than others in
particular there they're different these
different parametric functions that I
have to specify have different
constraints right so for the PDF
basically this the function needs to be
non-negative and needs to integrate to
one plus is a fairly calm
constraint to enforce the CDF needs to
be non-decreasing and have output that's
bounded between zero and one that's a
bit easier to enforce but might also
it's still a constraint that you need to
take care of and the quantile function
actually only needs to be non increasing
so any non decreasing function is a
valid quantile function of some
probability distribution so that makes
it a fairly good target for us of a
flexible parametric model that we want
to learn as an output from our neural
network because this constraint that the
output needs to be non decreasing is
fairly easy to enforce another reason
why one might want to choose this
quantile function as the output is that
the quartiles of the predictive
distribution is often what one is really
interested in when making forecasts and
so I wanted to mention one approach that
we developed that makes use of this of
modeling the quantile function as
opposed to modeling the density function
and what we did is basically to take the
look at this this quantile function and
parameterize it using piecewise linear
functions all right so basically you
break this range from zero to one in two
different sub intervals and you
approximate the function and each of
these sub intervals using a linear
function alright and the more of these
sub intervals you use the better your
approximation will be so this will give
you basically a piecewise linear spline
model for the quantile function and you
parameterize it basically by the
positions at which you switch between
different linear pieces so these are
called the knots of the spline and the
slopes that you have within each of the
intervals so each interval is a linear
function it has some slope and I get to
control that and so basically my overall
function approximation now has these two
vector parameters that control the knots
and the slopes of the function pieces
and then there is an additional
intercept which allows me to shift the
whole thing up and down
but especially a parametric form of the
that approximates my quantile function
or that represents my upon quantile
function and now what I could do is I
can take my neural network model and
train it to output these parameters
gamma B and D and then obviously train
it to such that the distribution the
quantile function that I get out best
matches the data that I have observed
and the way I do that is basically as
before or at least in principle it's
exactly the same I use a scoring rule so
before I was mentioning that I could use
likelihood as a scoring rule but I also
mentioned the continuous rank
probability score which is shown here so
CRPS for short and it's at a high level
it's the role is exactly the same as the
log likelihood write it busy it takes an
observation as at T so a single number
and it takes a representation of my
quantile function Q here and it computes
some loss and it does it in such a way
that the loss is minimal if my
distribution perfectly matches my data
so if my data is exactly drawn from the
distribution that I am modeling and
there's actually is a nice a nice view
on the CRPS score that is each of these
individual functions lambda here is
actually a quantile loss function of
some particular quantile alpha and the
co p s is just the integral of these
quantile losses over all the different
Quantrell levels so you can think of it
of trying to learn a model that predicts
different quantiles but does it for all
quantile simultaneously and it gets
around some some problems that you might
have with models that try to predict
multiple quantiles individually for
example the quantile crossing problem
where you have a quantile with a higher
quantile 'evil ending up having a
smaller value than the lower quartile
and you can now combine the
blind Quantrell output and the CRPS loss
function was any of the the neural
network architecture as I described
earlier where for example I could take
the deep layer model where I output at
each time point this the Y T parameters
which the way I described it previously
were the mean and the variance of the
Gaussian distribution and now I could
take those YT parameters and use them to
parameterize my spline so now that would
be my not positions at my slopes of my
linear piecewise linear function and
then instead of the log likelihood I
would be using the CRPS to train the
model but everything else would stay
identical ok so this is just the I one
thing that I will not talk about in
detail but something that I wanted to
mention is that of course Ganso
generative adversarial model networks
are I guess every and everybody's mind
right now so they're they're very
popular and so I of course you can also
apply gun type techniques to forecasting
in this or by just taking the very
standard gun setting where you have a
general term a model which gets some
noise as input and tries to predict or
tries to produce a fake time series and
then a discriminator model which tries
to decide what other thing that is
observed was actually something produced
by the generator or something produced
or something coming from the training
set and then basically training the the
model to the generator to fool the
discriminator by making better and
better predictions and the discriminator
tries to get better and better at
deciding which one came from the
generator and which one came from the
real training set and this has been
applied in the forecasting setting i put
a reference here so you can do that I
haven't seen particularly strong results
come out of this in the forecasting
setting but it might just be a matter of
time until until this also gets applied
very successfully
okay so this is it from from my part of
this tutorial I wanted to thank you for
your attention and I will hand it over
to Valentin we will be talking about
convolutional neural networks next thank
you very much